hello and welcome to a special ITV News
digital debate tonight we have gathered
a panel of guests from around the world
will explore how smartphones and social
media in general are revolutionising
understanding of journalism
about
attack in broad daylight a British
soldier is murdered on the streets of
London with bloodied hands one of the
killers boasted on camera moments after
the attack
along with the country music's his
arrest for a speeding was captured on
video for officers stun king with a
laser gun then beaten kicked him
repeatedly
I got well my family dead
earlier more than 30 shots were smashed
this a sweet shot whoa captured on a
mobile phone camera gunfire on campus
that seems as if it will never end one
of the survivors took these pictures
with the camera in her mobile phone look
at this oh gosh
well we are ladies and gentleman thank
you very much indeed a warm welcome to
those of you here in London and around
the world watching online I'm mark
Austin and this is an ITV News special
digital debate brought to you in
partnership with intelligence squared
and Google now it's difficult to get
away from cameras these days from the
surveillance cameras on the street that
film our every move to these smart
phones in our pockets but how many of us
use those devices for more than snapping
the odd selfie or boring our friends
with our holiday pictures almost a year
ago a young British soldier was murdered
in London on a street in broad daylight
the killer was filmed by an ordinary
bystander using his mobile phone as the
killer explained why he had carried out
the brutal attack the footage was used
on ITV news that night in the Middle
East in Syria and in Egypt smartphones
are being used to expose atrocities and
in so doing shape world opinion and
these cameras are being used in areas by
and large where the mainstream media
can't reach helping to provide a voice a
voice for those who cannot normally be
heard
smartphones together with all the other
kinds of social media have made all of
us much more powerful and better
informed as citizens but with that power
of course comes responsibility should we
always believe what we see if we don't
know who's operating the camera or where
it was filmed or when it was filmed is
this new breed of so-called citizen
journalism playing an important role in
delivering news or helping us deliver
news or is it simply distorting our
understanding of world events and what
does the mainstream media need to learn
from all this what do we need to
carefully consider when it comes to
broadcast
largely unfiltered and potentially
provocative material well without
further delay let me introduce the
panelists to to my right we have the
author and journalist will self we also
have the renowned war photographer Paul
Conroy who was seriously injured in the
Syrian city of Homs in the same attack
in which the Sunday Times journalist
Marie Colvin a great friend to some of
us here was killed
to my left Oran yaqoub ovitch founder of
the dare a a human rights group that
works to expose violations of human
rights around the globe through largely
through secret and covert filming and
also to his left the renowned
libertarian writer and director of
Britain's Institute of ideas and star of
moral maze and all things on radio for
Clare Fox now joining us on Google
hangout is from New York with filmmaker
and vice news reporter Simon Ostrovsky
who we are very lucky to have he was
recently held captive for three days by
pro-russian separatists in eastern
Ukraine we're also hoping I should point
out to make contact with Jessica Mabry
the founder of video volunteers which is
an organization which brings journalism
training to some of the some of India's
poorest communities later gentlemen our
panel
now you don't just have to be in this
room wherever you are you can put
questions to the speakers for those of
you watching online we have our web host
Charlene white charlie thanks very much
mark yes we do want to make sure that
you guys get involved in the discussion
here just because you're not physically
here in London doesn't mean that you
can't post your question to the panel
and take a take part in debate generally
actually we use them a hash tag hash tag
iq2 news that's iq2 news and for those
of you who are in the audience and you
will be seeing that flash up every now
and then up on the screens in here so if
you're on Twitter if you're on Facebook
make sure you go to the intelligence
squared Facebook page also go to that
Google+ page as well where we do have an
online debate happening there too
so make sure you do get your questions
in lots of you have already taken part
in the debate and I will be putting
those questions to our panel a little
bit later on so just to reiterate the
hashtag is hashtag iq2 news mark okay
thanks Charlene now to kick off I think
it'd be useful to give our panelists a
minute or so just to set out their views
on citizen journalism we can start with
Orin and how would you define citizen
journalism first of all and how useful
is it today
I guess very useful so what we're seeing
is phenomenon or a trend that happening
in the last year's but citizen have
cameras thanks to technology development
and what we're seeing is a lot of images
that we usually can't see through
traditional media is basically taking
two things that are problematic with
traditional media first thing journeys
cannot be everywhere and we all know
that all going bankrupt now so they have
lessen as journalists all over and in
second second of all they cannot be on
the ground all the time giving an
ongoing account about what's really
happening and this can be solved with
citizen journalism though they have the
problems there also because first of all
it's under 30 many cases and and also
still with all the technology there's
many places around the world that people
don't have smartphone they don't have
technology this is why we add era trying
to go to places in media can't or won't
go and bill under cover sustainable
network of people can give us an ongoing
full of information from places usually
we can't see images otherwise alright so
you say it's very useful Eclair I know
you're more skeptical about the role of
citizen journalist well I'm in very
enthusiastic about new technology and
it's undoubtedly the case not having
pictures and images instantaneously that
you can see what happened whether it's a
Boston bombing or so on and is
invaluable but it's not journalism
that's my only point
and journalism is a lot more than just
putting the camera and showing the
pictures it's developing context it's
being skeptical it's being one of the
awkward squad who asks awkward questions
there are standards involved there is
not taking at face value what you see
and I suppose I have a nervousness that
you know just if you think you can
understand a war by just seeing a bomb
go off and lots of blood and it becomes
actually it's almost like a video game
you're kind of watching if you never
understand anything and it's whose blood
why did the bomb go off who planted it
and the pictures don't tell you that and
similarly or slightly differently I
think that journalists mainstream
journalism should hold its nerve it has
a responsibility for some kind of
objective search for the truth which I
still think is an ideal worth holding on
to and I feel that they themselves are
handing over the reins in a kind of
Craven paranoid way to citizen generally
saying oh maybe we don't know what we're
doing at all and you lot know better and
maybe we can ingratiate ourselves with
the public by telling you how empowering
this is where so I just think citizens
with cameras good not journalism all
right we'll self mainstream journalism
should hold its nerve well I think it's
already you know the horse's head has
already been pulled from the Baltic and
we can see that the heels struggling to
exit its eye sockets I mean the revenue
stream for mainstream news media is
imperiled at the moment and actually
citizen journalism I'm making quote
marks if you can't see me is coming into
this Clare said to fill this vacuum so I
rather take layers lining as a mistake
too
all it journalism it's not what it is
think of one of the most egregious
examples recently which was the the use
of chemical weapons in in Syria and
there was an atrocity there that came to
light in the form of smartphone
journalism
it could looked for a while as if it was
a this was actually going to trigger
Ground Force invasion by the u.s. of
Syria it now seems as if that
attribution that the Bashar al-assad
regime was responsible for the attack
was in fact not the case so here you can
see an example where you know
decontextualized citizen journalism in
some sense could have precipitated a
human rights violation on a gargantuan
scale so I know I'm very skeptical
actually the value of this kind of
footage alright and Paul you actually in
Syria as a photographer there you
presumably worked with citizen
journalists how useful were they and how
you know easy or difficult was it to
believe what they were
yeah I'm showing you it made I mean ask
ourself with you know Marie's whole
philosophy a reason was to bear witness
and you know that's what rover that's
October was really so we got into Syria
um
yeah where is it room full of people
with wires everywhere extremely brave
people who were going out and filming
and every day some of the be killed and
they were getting fewer and fewer so
there was no doubt in their their
bravery but being alongside then we
relied on them for safety food shelter
which made the job twice as difficult so
they were your protection they were our
protection but we could never take what
they said without actually you know we
wouldn't dream of a printing hearsay we
would go to the spot and that's where I
think professional journalists come into
their own they go further Marie was
incredible at gone one step fair there
one step fair that one step further till
we'd really both realize we got the end
the line and this was in fact it's near
the truth is we could work out you know
where is most people had kind of taken a
picture it was on YouTube instantly and
it was never that depth and you know I
mean I could set on YouTube give me 20
minutes with an edit suite and I can
tell you any 30 you're like taking that
footage I can tell you in it which is
quite alarming um yeah Simon I'm really
good yeah Simon in New York now you
obviously I've seen your work for Vice
TV in Ukraine a very interesting
development in journalism in itself but
were you using or relying on citizen
journalists when you were there in
Ukraine what's happened over the last
couple of months is that they've as you
probably know been taking over a lot of
administration buildings a lot of
government facilities even military
bases on both sides from the Ukrainian
side in the in Kiev in the capital and
from the pro-russia side in eastern
Ukraine and what's developed is that a
lot of people have started setting up a
livestream webcams outside of these
buildings where permanent occupations
are taking place and those have been
really useful to pretty much everyone
who's following what's going on there to
know what's going on all of the time
because these live streams they can run
for days or they switch them on when
there's something happening outside of
the building but I wouldn't really call
them journalism as much as activism
because you know a live stream set up in
front of the occupied administration
building in eastern Ukraine and Donetsk
for example will be used by the
pro-russian activists in order to know
whether they need more people to come
out in front of the protest in the
building or you know in queue it'd be
the same thing for the pro Ukraine
protesters so they kind of use it for
coordination but US journalists can
follow the the cameras that have been
set up all over the country to know
what's going on where okay so imma thank
you for that which is this is the point
where we can open up the debate
people from the audience can ask their
questions and as I say just raise your
arm and someone will peel the microphone
just stand up and we don't need your
name or life stories or anything like
that if your online post your comments
and questions using that hashtag iq2
news that's hashtag iq2 news but the
kick start we have a question from
someone you may recognize in Los Angeles
and it's not Piers Morgan hi everybody
I'm Larry King and I wish I could be
there with you this evening but since I
can't I have a couple of questions for
the panel first how is eyewitness and
amateur journalism changing the shape of
news and affecting for better or for
worse the work of the mainstream media
second our citizen reporters now vital
members of the news industry or are they
simply karaoke journalists hey I look
forward to hearing your answers and I
wish you all the best
well karaoke journalism says Larry King
what would you make of that will self
well I think the best definition of
journalism I ever heard was HL Mencken's
and he said that journalism exists to
afflict the comfortable and comfort the
afflicted and I certainly as a
journalist that's my watchword and if
you think about that definition it does
cover all the bases
but it also says something about the
relationship between objectivity and
neutrality as well we're very used to
this line beginning to be blurred and
people have already talked about it you
know smartphone journalism really being
activism but what I think we need to
understand here is that the job of the
journalist is yes as Mary and Paul have
done to bear witness but it's up to us
to do what we will with what they bear
witness about if we tell people what to
do then that is propaganda it's not
actually journalism it's propaganda of
one kind or another now let's take the
attack on the rig B which is a very good
example of this british soldier these
these men stop him and attack him in the
street I saw that footage as it appeared
on now when I see anything in joy it was
very shocking footage it was happening
virtually live when you see anything
like that
run the Menken test is it afflicting the
comfortable and comforting the affected
if it is comforting the afflicted ie
people are disempowered in society
either economically politically or
socially then it in that case it can
only be comforting them in the form of a
rather grotesque form of entertainment
you look at that we can now see a man
who's just tried to heck off another
man's head live on telling isn't that
exciting and I have to say I think there
is a free soul that lies behind a lot of
this smartphone footage it is just that
a form of comfort that I've anything
responsible journalism if it comfort it
should be involved in second point does
it afflict the comfortable as an example
journalism in other words does the
ability that the news media and theory
now have to draw on this very wide pool
of instantaneous imagery is it being
used to present information in such a
way that it challenges vested interests
and again I'm afraid a lot of this
smartphone journalism doesn't really
pass that test either all right we can
now introduce Jessica Mabry from Goa in
India it was a monsoon I think or it's
just the beginning of the monsoon season
so it looks a condo first day the
monsoons today so the powers been out
until about three minutes ago all right
well that we're glad to have you um I
just want to ask you where does
journalism end and activism start
because I suppose you could be described
as an activist rather than journalist I
mean I think there's a real continuum
between it you and that they go hand in
hand where we talk about is video for
change you know we we have this net very
large network of what we call community
correspondents people from the most
marginalized backgrounds in India who
work as reporters but they don't just
make the videos they then use them to
try to solve the problem that the video
addresses so I think that the two
oh you know go very well hand in hand I
mean that that in our own people can be
journalists for most of what they do but
when they see an opportunity to use that
video to solve the problem they will
seize it and they you know and the
reason that they do that is because they
see so much that that's what the people
in their communities want the sense of
voiceless Ness and marginalization is
really is really there they don't feel
represented by the mainstream media yeah
but it's a good point isn't it that
Claire that the citizen journalism can
cover stories that mainstream media just
not interested in well there's two
aspects to I mean I've been involved in
politics most of my life as an activist
and I'm certainly not opposed to
political activists using the media to
get their message out but that's not
what we're talking about that's not
journalism that's activism an activist
will do whatever they will to
propagandize to pull Emma sighs to argue
and good on them right but journalists
could use the material of activists but
they could but they've got to know it's
activist advocacy material and therefore
it doesn't necessarily hold up the
strenuous examination in terms of a
sense of how does this fit into the
context so you have to say that I mean
the other thing is is that this tendency
has led to some real distortions because
you get people who there's examples of
people adding smoke to videos to as they
say embellish the urgency of why we need
to intervene for the greater truth even
even things like the you know and so you
have to remember that this sense of an
attached activist journalism actually
doesn't necessarily give you the truth
and what I'm saying is we should at
least aspire to the truth well it
actually won't know what to be active
about actually unless somebody finds out
what the truth is either well that's a
point for you is that because this whole
question of verification yes okay the
first of all I want to say that we kind
of a bit it gets stuck in the definition
of journalism definition is general I
don't know if you saw Fox News lately
these agenda they're the garden have
agenda everybody have agenda and kind of
you can that debate the kind of deck
currency sometimes and how verify the
information is now I think they
way that we see news today is going to
change I think the whole landscape is
shifting completely
I think generating will completely
different you have to make sure you
verify the information that you have a
currency that you be aware of people
have an agenda and that you know we're
working with activities across the world
that definitely have agenda but any
working variety of groups have different
agenda and compared them and give it to
the journalists name you can't verified
it okay do your own testing so but I
mean we were laughing a poor saying but
I mean how easy is it now - you know
Photoshop would have you pull this stuff
and change it and add smoke you can add
gunfire I mean it's easier mean change
the date on a big really honest you know
you picked their camera door you look
back to be the last young 90 years the
great photographs that sand down
people's memory Oh No disemboweled
bodies are pee with the heads shut up
you know they're their iconic images the
vulture with the starvin child you had
napalm and curing and absolutely yeah
and and that isn't what happens with the
smartphone you know people will see some
wandering around Ben and and just film
it and that's kind of it in a way it's
it's a bit like warp on you know it's
put on YouTube and you can watch someone
at the head sawed off with a rusty blade
whatever you know I mean it's my job to
be there and you'll want to share it's a
fan and everyone goes Bella's
timeless you've got to be able to get
the camera focus look at it think about
it from an editorial point of view ie
will they use it you've got to tell the
story I'm gonna capture it and then you
combine it with two and a half thousand
words by an experienced journalist like
Marie Colvin it's the sum is greater
than the two bars and that's what makes
journalism
I think it's monster in painting that's
read don't know um but Charlene what
what questions were getting online we're
getting quite we're get a lot of
questions in at the moment thank you to
everyone who's been facebooking and
tweeting over the over the last 20
minutes or so I've got a question here
from Joshua Swain who's in London who
says do or should news agencies take a
different view to editing or censoring
material gathered from citizen
journalists I'd agree with Claire and be
worried that system journalism could
never tell more than one side of the
story and Simon in terms of what you
were talking about regarding Ukraine
that's an interesting question that's an
interesting question
because is it possible to get both sides
the story from citizen journalists all
activists I think the issue of
verification is pretty important you you
never know what you're looking at really
when you see something on the internet
so I mean for my work what we've been
using it for mostly is taking our cues
for what's going on when we see
something on a live stream for example
and then going down there and checking
it out ourselves and we only use the
actual you know live stream footage or
smartphone footage if it's the only shot
available that documents something that
happened and it's you know key to a
story that we're working on but we'll
never try to you know base an entire
story on unverified footage I think
that's very important to do is to go
back and check and go to the places
where it was shot and try to make sure
that it actually represents what's what
it's been what it's showing what it's
saying that it's shown well and it seems
to be a question which seems to be
repeated actually online marks I have
another question and from manouschka
mujtaba he says how do you verify
citizen journalists journalists have to
verify sources is the criteria the same
I saw you were nodding your head well
well I just want to interrupt actually
slow because here Tim singleton is here
someone could give him a microphone and
he is director of news gathering at ITV
News and was foreign editor for a
considerable time and I know has dealt
with pictures and material coming in
from sources that we can't confirm I
mean for instance the material that
we'll be receiving from Syria during the
chemical attack time and all that
material how do you go about deciding
what we should
broadcast as part of our coverage and
what we shouldn't it's getting more
difficult over time I mean there are
different shades of gray here you know
if a plane crashed outside this church
now god forbid it'd be pretty easy to
verify it
you know big events happen and people
are taking pictures of it I think
conflicts like Syria where access for
independent journalist is is becomes
increasingly difficult especially in the
last 12 months almost impossible
especially from from from the West how
then do you verify it when it's hard to
get meaningful contacts you're not
trusted by anyone because we're from
from from a part of the world where
we're not welcome in Syria I mean how do
you go about doing that it's the biggest
problem we face at the minute and it's
magnified in a sense we've always needed
citizen journalists when we've been out
you know fixes as we would call them in
the field
translators whatever we've always use
citizen journalists but now they're
empowered with the means of delivery of
material to which completely changes the
concept of things you mentioned people
setting fire to to what ones I've seen I
think a channel for program exposed it
whether it's set fire to tires and to
put the smoke up and then claimed it as
an attack and shot it in a way that
didn't show the tires there's all
different ways of manipulating things so
it's a feed of the temptation there
probably to use it if it's really good
and then say in the intro or something
we can't verify this material which
comes out as a way of help yeah your
comparative and I'm sure it is just as I
think the moment people see unverified
on the screen I've spoke to people today
about a vigil switcher you see the
problem is is the impact that could have
bit these these sort of pictures can
start wars yeah but it's also not
pictures I mean I you know it really
struck me we saw the Boston bombs I mean
yes there were people who were on they
were there and film the Boston bombs but
as you'll know then on Twitter other
people are saying there's bomb going off
all over Boston because there's smoke
coming out and then so this gets
repeated let alone the manhunt which
made
media almost followed Twitter and
apparently you know I witness on the
ground authentic material which led to
also you know people getting arrested
you shouldn't have being accused of
being bombers all sorts of confusion so
I think it's more than just you've got
the footage my concern is that
mainstream media and I said earlier on
kind of it becomes slightly over
dependent on the social media sense and
and feel somehow that it's more
authentic because it's coming from the
people that I think is really that I
think is really our problem it's a kind
of it's more it's more than just you've
got the film it's a more existential
crisis as it were as to what journalism
is and that's what I would I would urge
us to kind of consider more seriously
does anybody in the audience have a
question they'd like to put to the panel
yeah there's a lady here just wait for
the microphone I don't think this is
existential isn't this financial this is
about money and what's going to be paid
for who's going to get paid you think it
citizen journalism isn't filling a gap
because people aren't spending money on
covering foreign news and well well
different that I mean that is a
dangerous a genuine danger isn't it if
we if we can't finance bureaus around
the world and sending journalists around
the world citizen Jen's going to fill
the gap no I don't think it is it's
great I think you know I was lucky
enough to wear under Sunday times and
there was never elevate sorry
27 weeks in Libya
did the whole thing was never a question
of money it was like yo sure kept a big
bag of cash and we plug it up and we
work a murder Tim I know I think the
question that raises is is actually I
would say that mainstream media
organizations are still committed to
reporting the world and actually as as
people are more aware of the uncertainty
of the accuracy of information on the
Internet actually we're more important
and as relevant as than ever a
mainstream media organization is now
having it's imperative that we continue
to bear witness to send to have bureaus
and to report from from around the world
because we have to confront the fact
that a lot of material on the internet
isn't reliable I mean I was talking to
journalism students a few weeks ago and
the first question I got was aren't you
now you're half our program in the
evening on terrestrial television isn't
it now redundant because it's all on
Twitter and there's all the system
journalism going on and I made the point
that it is in many ways with more
important now not less important time do
you agree with that yeah and I think we
very much depends how we would consume
use in the future and I bet in 20 years
nobody going to read or people better
read but much less than today and I'm
going to count on video short videos
showing us what's happening I think that
is extremely important that we'll have a
very good mainstream or traditional
journalists that are doing the work
correctly
I disagree that they are everywhere look
what's happening Karl South Sudan they
are there but after the event is
happening they are not there before to
show us what's happening and if they
were there before maybe we will not see
what we're seeing after so they still
lack of coverage across many places in
the world and definitely when you know
dramatic images automatic advance emerge
dangerous flying in most of the time
after the events really already exploded
it's a point isn't it well so that the
stories that perhaps emerge on by you
know through citizen journalism do you
become big stories and the you know then
the organizations do spend the money and
do send because it's causing such a up
to a noise online up to a point Lord cop
I mean the fact of the matter is and I
think the the woman there was right of
course it's money to a certain extent
and of course it's about revenue streams
but also though it seems to be with the
new media a kind of weird new febrile
sense of how things develop in the world
you know we saw it in the Arab Spring we
saw it in the lead-up to the Iranian
elections we've now seen it in the
Ukraine and there are some mainstream
media sources and pundits who are quite
keen to exploit this febrile mood and
what it amounts to it's like a sort of
perversion of the McLuhan eye Global
Village the idea is because everybody's
tweeting about everything and because
everybody's sitting in this smartphone
material we must do something and we can
it's this idea of empowerment and
actually I think what it does is it
creates an atmosphere of hysteria if you
like this the transmission country
there's eastern Ukraine now and there's
people sing in London or New York or
Beijing or wherever they are going oh
that's red 'fl oh look at that footage
all we really involved is live in fact
they're decoupled from their own
political process and from the own their
own forms of civic and communal action
and activism that will enable them to
affect that so that you know what does
it do all of that kind of brouhaha what
does that actually do or produce and who
gets to use this head of effectively
useless steam that this kind of material
generator
let's take question moving on from what
we'll just said and does smartphone
journalism risk glamourizing violence we
were talking about war reporting that's
a very specific category but think about
something like happy-slapping which
would never have existed if there wasn't
smartphone footage that could be put on
YouTube are we creating a whole
generation of people who want to be
famous or infamous for some violet back
but I mean that's definitely and fits
into the war hole Ian
minutes of fame we know all about that
but just to tell you something because
you're nice and young people are about
older here may remember and I remember
this from my childhood when TV cameras
and had the ability to send back instant
film footage and conflict situations
first began to happen it was the Vietnam
War unmediated footage went on to the TV
screen in the evenings and anybody who's
you know older than 50 will remember
seeing stuff on mainstream news that
would be unthinkable now it took a while
for news media to understand what a
responsible relationship with that kind
of footage was and then it was developed
we're in currently in an inchoate
situation and yes I mean I hate to sound
kind of big brother-ish but it is the
responsibility of mainstream news media
to try and develop a way of dealing with
that material and developing an ethic
around them short Jessica you were
waving or what was the point you wanted
to make you know we're talking here as a
citizen journalism is only the kinda
cellphone footage that comes through
right it's only accidental video it's
only witnessing video but I think you
know we can take a longer-term
perspective and well you know there are
there are other questions like what why
are we just missing the raw footage what
about the voices of you know of people
are using I mean how come you never you
so rarely sees the dissin journalism of
actually hearing people from these
countries these countries speaking out
and even less so do you see do you see
news agencies giving a space for people
to tell to actually tell the entire
report to get there three minutes on two
you know on to CNN and onto these onto
these different channels and I think
that's you know to me that's where it
may be 20 years for now and and then we
ask that you know then it's sort of we
ask the question like what's what's the
role of subjective personal experience
it's definitely not you know it's not
journalism and the way that we're
talking about here but it's but
an important ancillary and it's one of
the things that technology has enabled
no it's the the field is changing
technology is always changing whether
it's photography or its print it's every
time there's a new technology it pushes
the boundaries and it's I think it's a
real opportunity
what citizen journalism presents a real
opportunity to start to change you know
a lot of things okay Jessica thanks I
just want to take the question here from
the general I would just like to say so
that the Arab uprisings were kind of the
source or the trigger for this debate I
don't think the debate can be
constructive enough without considering
the voices of the Arab activists or the
Arab TuneIn citizen journalist so I'm
wondering why there's no kind of another
activist part of the adult uprising
saying giving can say on this in this
debate thank you and good or maybe that
it just fits into what I was going to
say which is you know in a way that's
what my nervousness is because you could
say well if we had an arab activist here
that that would represent all arab
activists everywhere i mean we only have
to look at what's happened in egypt to
indicate that you know the Arab Spring
the enthusiasm around the Arab Spring
has turned into and what's happened in
Egypt has turned into a very vicious
bloody situation
military coos and so on which are of
activists that would be the question
okay well and then which footage did you
listen to was it only those by the way
who speak in English you know that this
can be manipulated this can be used
so all I'm arguing for is not to be over
simplistic it's a very attractive idea
isn't it the voices that were previously
not heard can now be heard
sometimes that sounds that sounds great
but it just seems to me to be hopeless
it's just a babble a rabble of voices
unless we understand why we're listening
to them and what they mean in a
particular context we have been
pre-release are not important it's
important to your voice and not heard it
question is what you're doing with them
how you verify them how you put you in
the right context how you two can even
reach in the way we are the silence
anyone but I'm also I don't want to be
semental it's a bit like blogging right
there can be millions of people now free
to blog and that's brilliant
I'm not trying to censor them but I do
think that there is some responsibility
to say that person who's just written a
blog and it's rubbish and they're not
saying anything and that is distinct
from a very fine well executed
well-written article right we have a
pre-recorded question think about it we
haven't really thought we have a pretty
retorted question we have a pre-recorded
question from a citizen journalist in
New York and his name is Nathan grant
everyone my name is Nathan grant and as
a citizen journalist I provided live
stream coverage of street protests such
as occupied wall street for two years
now because independent journalists are
more able to adapt to the ever-changing
means by which people consume their news
will it be through citizen journalism
then that new and exciting means of news
gathering are developed basically can
citizen journalism inspire more
mainstream outlets to give up their more
antiquated means of reporting news so
there's a question can citizen
journalism get mainstream journalism
into shape definitely yes I think it's
kind of you it's challenging mainstream
journalism and it's that's why reporter
and Mason didn't have to kind of shape
up and make sure that they know exactly
what they're doing and how they're
covering the whole voices I think we are
bit tired also of journeys flying into a
place you know standing in the wind
reporting about what's happening and
going out we want this voice also but
you want another voice in the circle and
to be get it and to present it so
definitely is challenging them you
remember to disagree with that and had a
shoes then then not everybody so don't
get me wrong
yeah of course spend a lot of time 100%
information what was it say before it
was channel for Jonathan Miller meant
fantastic documentary inside cities
Church with you with a Lorenza CLE
examined every single piece of footage
she got my
which experts in you know and clinical
people to look the ruins to listen to
the ballot and no that was an incredibly
complex task to verify that footage and
to me that is journalism let us take
that by looking at it and and not just a
little stick around with the question
how many really doing it and how many
did we need cross a lot of areas
actually yeah it definitely so this is
this is the channel to three hands and I
want to our Simon your Ukraine
experience to what extent do you think
that citizen journalists who are
sometimes you know an extension of the
of the armed conflict to what extent
that they in danger mainstream
journalist well I mean in terms of
professionally I don't think that they
endanger them very much because I think
that the two can exist side by side and
kind of even complement each other but
if you mean like in a purely physical
sense I think the citizen journalists
are mostly endangering themselves I mean
when I was being held in the basement of
the security services building in
sloviansk in eastern Ukraine I met a
citizen journalist a guy who set up a
live stream across the street from the
very building that we were being held in
a week before and the reason that he was
taken by the pro-russian militants was
that they'd seen the live stream online
and didn't want him running it so that
he's just been released a couple of days
ago um luckily and just given a press
conference about his experience in Kiev
earlier today but you know he spent
three weeks compared to my three days
because he wasn't known by anyone he
didn't represent any company he just put
his stuff on a livestream website and
they knew that they could hold him and
nobody would really care um luckily
though he's out now thanks to that site
Simon Charlene are we getting some yeah
lots actually and ina put this question
to
you know the one that I would actually
wanted to get to is some hail Wharton
burg who's in Ghana he says is it fair
to diminish smartphone journalism the
best journalism gives audiences stories
and smartphones afford all of us the
ability to spread stories probably good
lumpy Ukiah as I've tried to indicate
and first of all I've got no objection
to people using smartphones to tell
stories that's fine and but I but I I
thought it was interesting the
accusation of the kind of flying in
whereas there are these people embedded
who lived there who know what's going on
but there's something about the flying
in analogy that actually I want to hold
on to because it's called
being disinterested being outside of the
main story you're not a participant in
the story you're there and - and you
know sometimes we will say isn't it
inhuman that journalists can watch these
terrible things children dying and not
get involved but their job a very
specific job which I could never do yeah
that them is to actually have that
objective and sort slightly cynical
slightly skeptical viewing so it's not
that they don't understand anything
about the region they're experts you in
a way or outside of the situation so if
you're there on the ground telling
stories with your smartphone that's a
very nice thing to do with your life but
we actually in serious terms do need to
understand we live in a serious times
and I need to know that there is some
people who are dedicated to trying to
get to what's going on and why and what
lies behind the surface of things not
the eyewitness or the activists there
are political jobs somewhere else but
journalism's got a very important role
and I worry that it that it doesn't that
it needs to take itself more seriously
it's more important today than ever
before and therefore shouldn't shouldn't
worry too much just one tiny thing is
this idea as well as citizen journalists
should tell about the news that the news
the mainstream news won't tell right
some of this can think about what this
can mean it drives me mad when you get
those things that flash up on the news
which says email in the news that
matters to you I mean you do think the
one group of people you don't ask what
the new should be is me I don't know
right what I know is what
no and therefore it's not going to be
new to me what I want is somebody to say
to me you think it's really boring to
find out what's happening Ukraine it's
got no relevance to you whatsoever you
don't think it's important but I'm going
to bash you over the head with why it's
important that's why they're in the news
they shouldn't call popularity but they
should convince us of why it's important
not give us what we want we don't need
to be pander to in that way yeah follow
moves later now and when we were in Homs
we were in a media center with a lot of
guys set men in a statement well to say
that all over the world and this comin
for 28 days in incredibly horrible
shelling of their disabilities and it
was the most disgusting thing I've ever
witnessed that media sent it operated a
long time
mer even on the news one night channel 4
in DC and CNN the next one of four
guards took out the media center and you
know I mean it's almost about talent
because she was ready because people
trust them then you know they it rattled
too many cages in Damascus and major
said say sunny authorities knew we were
broke and probably and I think I notice
in many ways they've allowed a constant
flow of media to be uploaded because it
caused confusion the more material it is
the more confused people get a question
from the gentleman up there he's been
very patient good evening thank you um
doesn't successful journalism actually
being made up of two parts first is the
collection of the data and then secondly
the interpretation and verification of
that data or that journalism all that
news or whatever it happens to be
citizen journalism really deals with the
collection part and the reason that I
don't get my news from YouTube is
because there isn't any interpretation
or verification I do get it from ITV and
I don't get it from
today what is that it's a good point
isn't it yeah definitely I I think we
can be recruiting in the same basket
variety of means of reporting in variety
of kind of you know people filming their
dog being drowned somewhere and they've
been bombed so it's kind of we're very
generalizing which we're making a whole
and generalization about a lot of cities
and journalism there are some that are
very important and very crucial you
cannot get the information without
activists on the ground filming risking
their life and definitely great
journalists to take these materials and
work with it verify that making part of
the story so just how you combine both
together and how you're looking at it
you cannot ignore this in journalism and
dismiss it I give to be very articulate
of whether we use it and make sure that
is reaching the picture that we and
deprecating to the world um
I think just for the final part of the
way I think we want to know from each of
the panel where journalism will be in
say 10 years time where the convergence
will be maybe between citizen journalism
and mainstream journalism I just wonder
what you think of that will self first
well I mean it's a question of revenue
it is a question follow the money it's a
question of revenue streams terrestrial
television broadcast and Prem media are
all suffering from problem of the
relationship between what they provide
and what they're paid for that simple
relationship is really you know a
debatable area at the moment it's
debatable and I'm confident and I hate
agreeing with Claire but I'm going to
have to it is a question of nerve on the
part of mainstream media on keeping
nerve and I think it is rather woeful
this you know I totally take on world
what you're saying but what we see in
mainstream media at the moment is
actually quite supine in relation to
citizen journalism it isn't actually
policing it in the great kind of way if
I could just say something further on
the Hat on the activist issue and on the
kind of appeal to kind of sensibility oh
if there weren't people there with smart
phones filming this stuff going on how
would we know about it how could we do
anything about
okay what would it be like all those
voices are heard you know we live in a
society in which there are very few
taboos any more about the portrayal of
sex and violence if you go back 40 or 50
years there was an astonishingly
governed public space everybody could be
heard actually now nobody's listening
though it's too much of it there's too
much of it so what would it be like if
all of those Indian activists out there
you know in the region were all heard in
some sense well the answer is to have a
society in which everything was heard by
everybody would of course be a kind of a
narco communist exede devolved power so
that's the kind of paradigm the idea of
a fully functioning citizen journalists
culture is a utopian Simon Ostrovsky if
I could come to you um you are breaking
new ground in some respects in the way
you cover news and the way you deal
where do you think well where do you
think journalism and citizen journalism
will be in ten years time well I look
forward to the to everything evening out
so where will not have to carry around
big heavy cameras and be very obvious
and where we'll be able to film all of
our reports on stones and therefore will
kind of be on an even playing field with
everybody else and then the people who
will stand out are the ones who put
their content together better in a more
interesting in a more informative way
but with the same tools that everybody
can afford ok Simon thanks about Claire
Claire um ten years time where will we
be well I I find it extraordinary that
on them journalism courses at the moment
at universities they're teaching citizen
journalism which seems to be so
oxymoronic is untrue but it seems to me
that journalism is trying to ape citizen
journalism too much so that worries me
an analogy maybe and is it drives me mad
that that you know newspapers and
editors seem to imagine that they can
see the quality of a newspaper article
by how often it's retweeted or how many
comments there are at the bottom of it
this is what I mean about a kind of
collapse of editorial confidence and the
ability to be able to say that's
important piece of journalism and
nobody's retweeted and no one's written
a comment but that's not the way things
are going that worries me and just and
one thing is I'm not complacent about
mainstream journalism by the way I you
know I was already to say eyewitnesses
aren't a risk you know if you think
about John Charles too many a and the
eyewitness accounts he was wearing a
bulky jacket he ran over that you know
he jumped and of course it wasn't true
but loads of people saw it
so eyewitness we have to be careful
about but then I also remember the
toppling of the stabbim Hussein statue
and we were given the impression that
that was the masses and it was the end
of the Iraq war and that was mainstream
media that sold us that pop so we should
be on our guard as citizens to ensure
that journalism doesn't lower its
standards rather than thinking that we
are the journalists we should hold
journalists to very high journalistic
standards and absolutely do them over if
they try and sell us anything other than
the best of the truth all right now
definitely agree with you I do think
that in vedera we offer an interesting
solution for seasoned citizen journalism
we are not just collecting information
from outlets and about crowd sourcing
about targeted areas building network
training people making sure that this
come with its standard collecting
information verified and engaging to the
news some kind of interesting
combination between traditional media
and new source of citizen journalism so
I think finding finding the right
solution understanding there is you know
people coming with all kind of agendas
and objectives but finding the right
balance in between using them at once
and also using traditional media in the
right way we've got to take Jessica next
Jessica are we've lost Jessica I'm told
so I'm too late the monsoon is back so
it's you Paul
fiims no matter how difficult it was you
know so when it kicks out you know you
just think what could we do up that they
are eating where we drain people from
run problems going great like doing this
way that does nothing then does like
that they do do it the Braves they get
the pictures but it's typical tells you
train the whole world up too much empty
market responsible journalists and not
just they actually book because you're
talking about the future of journalism
I'll just talk here I'll just pop one of
the questions that we've had on Twitter
from at T Nagar Oh Roy he's in London he
says how does a panel feel about sites
like BuzzFeed moving into breaking news
based on content from smartphone
journalists is this the future oh yeah
any may affect our in disagrees I
insisted I can't make a point here about
this which I think has been slightly
overlooked what is what is the platform
for all of this the smartphone the
smartphone isn't a value neutral object
it's often on a contract it's owned by a
corporation it has an operating system
it comes with an awful lot of pathan you
know when when people go to meet and
talk my mind's gone blank the guy who
blew the whistle on prison the
whistleblower on the yeah when people
went to meet him journalists went to
meet him he said to them and switch
those smartphones off don't you realize
they can be used as recorders so you
know the idea that the smartphone is an
empowering device it's got a long trail
and the other thing is back to the
medium is the message
news tends to be perceived in the
context of the smartphone is on a par
with other smartphone II type things
it's like an air you know oh I've got
this kind of instant violence from the
eastern Ukraine app you know you're
coming I could laugh about it there's a
flattening of sensibility there you know
if we return sort of the whole in terms
of those specific websites like BuzzFeed
for example
I mean Oran you feel that this could be
the future in terms of sites like this
that are only doing breaking is based on
generated fits again I guess for a lot
of audience es very much depends you
know who is the audience and how you
gather and getting your information I
believe you know people are going to
continue reading the New York Times and
others and maybe that's the heavy
slapping of news it's what is here when
we register you have a site like vice
for which Simon rights for which it's
hugely popular but you wouldn't find you
know the New York Times right there
readers for example wouldn't necessarily
automatically go to vice doesn't devalue
what someone likes some and I know but
this is I don't I first of all I don't
want to start a moral panic about mobile
phone technology you know I can also
Skype my mom on it I can send her films
I mean I I think been able to take films
is a great thing and the technology is
exciting and so on but you know it's
just technology for good or bad the
thing the thing that worries me is I
really don't I mean you know people will
try and find new ways of doing news
coverage and that's fine and no one
should panic about that but what
BuzzFeed is saying is not news coverage
and it's really interesting because
BuzzFeed just before Christmas actually
their arts editor their new arts editor
came out and said we don't want any
negative reviews of any arts productions
we've decided we only want positive
feedback on any arts productions I call
that PR right they do good class but the
reality but I said that there's another
point it it gets another point here that
in some countries in too many countries
around the world journalists cannot
operate journalists get locked up
journalists get killed journalists get
targeted and in those countries surely
citizen journalism is often the only
outlet I mean in too many countries
around the world web where there is no
mainstream mainstream journalism doesn't
exist you had a question do you think
that moving into like a digital
revolution where we've got access to the
Internet and access for people to upload
news and then as soon as they take it do
you think that reputation is something
is going to play a part and within the
digital world you have things like
LinkedIn where people's personal
reputations can be shown online so you
can see some sort of insight into who
they are and what they do or stand for
it's that one
LinkedIn's about I'm constantly get
emails saying Claire Fox would like you
to join a little in a partnership I'm
libelous die instantly to lead them you
know one minute who wants something the
question you I I just think consider
Wikipedia you know I think it's got 21
million editors you must Google me when
you get home and look at Wikipedia all I
can say is it is not a reliable source
of information and my reputation will
suffer badly by asking you to Google
about me I mean hopefully you can google
me and see there's a lot of rubbish
written about me or anyone rotten
rubbish yeah I mean yeah you won't you
won't necessarily get you won't
necessarily get the truth is the point
but I'm making could I just pick up on a
point that was recently very briefly and
without being again kind of starry-eyed
about this
suppose you're in me an immoral so it's
meant be open more now but you're in a
closed country where you can't get
authentic news but there is citizen
journalists operating where is there
information going to and again it's not
authenticated and it is good so how is
it empowering the people in the closed
country actually people behind the Iron
Curtain during the Cold War listen to
the world service if they wanted to know
what was going on in Poland or you know
wherever said the idea that the citizen
journalism in some way is gonna help the
oppressed that's my dad is about it I
will jump in because this part of our
work it does help because you have to
understand what the theory of change
what you want to achieve it's going to
be a social change on the ground they're
going to use it for their own campaigns
inside going to be international media
is it going to be to court cases is
going to be spiritual in a bit it's
often being done to lobby mainstream
media in the West to do something
focusing on thank you very much indeed
that is it that's all we have time
ten thousand two hours thank you all for
coming thank you for being here and
contributing thanks to our panel will
self Paul Conroy or in your Kovich
Claire Fox and Simon thank you very much
to you there in New York and Jessica
wherever you are thank you very much
thanks to intelligence squared thanks to
Google for making the event possible the
debate is over discussion can continue
online Charlene is here for another 14
hours to share your thoughts with us but
from me mark Austin from everyone here
thank you very much good night